de rely on aimerait quand direct pour
tous par non pas à mon poste vous nous
fassiez faut mon dos mais elle est née
en moi parce que je prends mon courrier
parce que j'essaie 12 imité
alors vous allez nous faire deux trois
voix comme ça de croissance parce
qu'elle a une voix incroyable vous allez
voir chez vous vous êtes tous et à
chaque fois il scotché à chaque fois que
véronique fait quelque chose alors
véronique on restait barrée par isabelle
boulay keanu chanté par le mois
il y avait un imitateur extraordinaire
qu'il n'est pas content oui qui fait les
guignols j'attends votre mac guignols je
n'aurai pas la mer alors on commence
avec isabelle boulay alors tu es prêt
est ce que c'est bon c'est bon c'est
parfait alors tu es tu prêt je sais plus
comment te dire je ne trouvais leur
chante chante pas citer jean bouin ne
pas parler précisé
non non non en fait le fait que vous
faites le bouille alors on va pas le
faire ce club puis moi je moi je vais
lui offrait d'accord au part de moi je
ne suis plus commentées mais ni comment
te parler on a ça en azad allez-y je
verrai jamais arrivé d'en bas vous allez
voir alesi comment si j'arrive je veux
de l'amour la joie de l'ain venu à mon
bonheur
moi je crevais la main sur le club
allons ensemble découvrir ma liberté
oubliez donc tous vos clichés bienvenue
dans ma réalité
ce gamou la fable est ce qu'on va pas se
faire aux patients une petite vanessa
paradis
ok eh bien allez je vais arrêter d'en
dessous a dû commencer dès marie line va
voir d'ici disait fragile du t2 vie
divine et ils l'amour qui sommeille
temps ce souffle rien ma folie mon envie
mais alibi mon idée est dédié berlu du
caire qui est avec nous sont vraiment
allés la voir elle est en tournée dans
toute la france
[Musique]